hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
for my newsletter readers below be who
wrote insane please enlighten me on how
to discover and activate the leadership
and business potential in me so lowly
there's a couple things you can do the
first that i always find interesting and
helpful is to read books so find books
that inspire motivate you want to take
action leadership books entrepreneur
books i find that some of my best
mentors have come from people i don't
know but they're their authors who are
believed in their message or famous
entrepreneurs who i've read their story
and I get ideas from second deceive you
might be able to find a mentor and asked
to meet with people people you respect
people who might be able to bounce ideas
off of you've seen them grow their
business or you see them as a good
leader and you want to just tap their
mind ask them the coffee just to pick
their brain the first time and see if
you guys hit it off if you get some
ideas and third the most important one
is you have to take action so you learn
a lot from books and from meeting people
but you learn the most bite by doing it
you learn through doing and if you want
to learn to be a leader start taking
leadership positions it can be as easy
as hiring somebody off of Odessa to get
started or Alliance like hire your first
worker treat them with respect learn to
lead them give them pass involve them
and you'll learn a lot by actually doing
that then just reading about in the book
if you want to you know push the start
of business start a business you know
actually get out there and start a new
company try to sell your products or
service and the most important step you
could take two very business and to
learn these skills is to actually get
going instead of just reading their
meeting people so I hope that helps
maybe a little bit of a kick in the
pants to get started I'd love to hear
you guys have to say if you want to
leave a comment under video and I always
appreciate any thumbs up you want to
leave it gives me a lot of excitement to
see when you leave a thumbs up in the
video so thank you for those and stay
tuned for next episode
you
you